tu es avec roger gicquel campagne
nationale contre l'alcoolémie en 1977
cinq mille tués sur les routes
responsable l'alcool notre société face
à l'ordinateur menace ou rempart pour
nos libertés
le débat est ouvert à l'assemblée
nationale conférence de belgrade
le bulletin de santé de la détente deux
ans après le signe qu' il y a vingt ans
spoutnik 1 tourner autour de la terre
c'était le début de la conquête de
l'espace
bonsoir c'est de l'eau
bonsoir on ne peut pas en sortir c'est
encore une fois d'une france coupée en 2
qu'il faut s'occuper aujourd'hui la
france de ceux qui boivent et la france
de ceux qui trinquent
et ce sont parfois les mêmes d'un côté
ceux qui font le vin et les alcools
de l'autre ceux qui en abusent la ligne
de partage est très floue on pourrait
même dire comme en d'autres
circonstances qu'elle passe par le
milieu de chaque individu tandis que de
l'alsace au bord de la loire et du médoc
à la bourgogne
on célèbre les plaisirs du vin que l'on
vendange les pouvoirs publics désigne
l'alcoolisme comme étant le fléau
national récemment monsieur giscard
d'estaing annonçait une décennie de
lutte contre l'alcoolisme dans le
rapport sur la violence l'alcoolisme
était montré comme un facteur important
de criminalité et aujourd'hui on a donné
le coup d'envoi à une campagne contre
l'alcoolisme au volant avec ce titre
évocateur sur la route petit verre grand
danger
boire ou conduire il faut choisir à
l'appui de cette campagne on a cité un
chiffre impressionnant dans 40% des cas
de décès accidentel sur la route
le responsable de l'accident dépassaient
le taux d'alcoolémie toléré
cela résulte d'une enquête effectuée par
des gens qui ont la plus grande
expérience des accidents de la route en
france c'est à dire les chirurgiens de
l'hôpital de garches garches comme vous
le savez n'étant pas un hôpital de
province mais le centre le plus
spécialisée en france dans la survie des
grands blessés de la route
on peut donc faire confiance à ces
chiffres confirmaient d'ailleurs par la
gendarmerie nationale le professeur go
et son équipe travaillent sur 4000 cas
d'accident et les premiers résultats de
son enquête montre aussi que plus de la
moitié des automobilistes tués
dans un accident où il était seul en
cause présentait une alcoolémie
supérieure ou égale à 0,8
comme on pouvait s'y attendre les
producteurs d'alcool ont déjà réagi à
ces chiffres notamment la société ricard
qui a lancé une grande campagne avec
pages de publicité dans la presse où il
est affirmé que l'alcool n'intervient
que pour huit et demi pour cent des
accidents corporels et paul ricard
regrette que l'on consacre beaucoup
d'argent à discréditer nos produits et a
donné une bien piètre image de la france
et des français
campagne d'affichage contre campagne de
publicité voici donc un nouveau revenu
le temps des grandes polémiques sur
l'alcool mais à garches c'est un travail
sérieux objectifs et sur le terrain
qu'on s'est livrée enquête jean pirogue
quatre mille accidents mortels qui se
sont produits dans toute la france entre
le 1er janvier et le 30 juin de cette
année sont donc étudiés par l'équipe du
professeur go la gendarmerie et la
police fournissent tous les
renseignements qui permettent de
reconstituer ces accidents avec des
mannequins toutes ces données sont
soumises à l'ordinateur on analyse le
comportement du conducteur lorsque son
taux d'alcool dépasse le taux légal de
0,8 gramme par litre
les premiers résultats sont formels dans
40 % des cas
le responsable de l'accident à un taux
d'alcool supérieur au taux légal
jusqu'à présent on ne connaissait pas
exactement l'importance de l'alcoolisme
dans les accidents mortels
les chiffres fournis par le ministère de
l'intérieur et la gendarmerie concerné
l'ensemble des accidents corporels
tenez compte de toutes les personnes
impliquées dans un accident et non pas
seulement des responsables souvent aussi
les gendarmes n'avaient pas les moyens
de vérifier l'alcoolémie
l'équipe de l'hôpital de garches a
demandé son concours au corps médical au
samu pour que dans des zones tests
région par région les prises de sang
sont effectués le plus rapidement
possible après l'accident
pour lutter contre cette étude les
fabricants d'alcool ont lancé une
campagne publicitaire qui reprend des
chiffres publiés par le ministère de
l'intérieur il y a deux ans c'est à dire
avant l'étude du professeur go et qui ne
porte pas sur les accidents mortels mais
sur l'ensemble des accidents corporels
le chiffre bien sûr est beaucoup plus
bas 6,6 pour cent mais les données ne
sont pas les mêmes il est absolument
scandaleux qu'un marchand d'alcool
oppose avec mauvaise foi de statistiques
différentes qui n'ont pas les mêmes
bases et qui ne sont pas incompatibles
actuellement nous reprenons avec le
concours de la gendarmerie
une étude sur tous les accidents mortels
survenus en france dans les six premiers
mois avec les bases de l'enquète de
garches et l'on verra dans quelques
semaines si les résultats sont aussi
discordants que le présente actuellement
ce publicité
cette publicité est d'autant plus
scandaleuse que cette année 5000 morts
ont été provoqués par l'alcool dans 45%
des cas ce ne sont pas les victimes mais
les responsables qui avaient bu je crois
qu'il faut d'abord rappeler aux français
et pas laisser l'objet de cette campagne
d'information que l'on ne peut pas
conduire si l'on a bu il faut aussi
avoir des possibilités de contrôle alors
vous savez que nous avons une
législation qui est déjà contraignante
avec des possibilités de sanctions très
grave mais cette législation prévoit que
les contrôles ont lieu soit lorsqu'il ya
eu un accident soit ans lorsqu'il ya une
infraction et il est certain qu'il
faudrait pouvoir aller plus loin et
contrôler le degré d'alcool des
conducteurs dans d'autres circonstances
c'est d'ailleurs l'objet d'un projet de
loi qui a été adopté par l'assemblée
nationale et qui constitueraient un net
progrès pour la lutte contre l'alcool au
volant
cette loi permettra aux gendarmes
d'effectuer des contrôles a priori avant
l'accident
ce sera bien sûr la lutte la plus
efficace contre l'alcoolémie on n'a pas
fait exprès mais en pleine campagne
contre l'alcoolisme un rapport sur
l'avenir de la viticulture française au
conseil économique et social sera
présenté demain à la presse par louis
louga
l'ancien président du centre national
des jeunes agriculteurs
ce rapport qui aura au moins le mérite
d'être publié contrairement à celui
préparé il ya deux ans par un
fonctionnaire du ministère de
l'agriculture il faut croire que toutes
les vérités n'étaient pas bonnes à dire
à ce moment là ce rapport donc va tomber
au moment où les viticulteurs constate
avec les vendanges que l'année sera
moyenne déjà dans le midi viticole on
entend des murmures de déception alors
que l'an dernier on se plaignait de
l'abondance
il a beaucoup plu cet été la qualité va
s'en ressentir dans certaines régions et
l'on reparle de la fameuse
chaptalisation l'addition de sucre au
vin pour en augmenter le degré plus il y
à deux degrés plus le vin est payé cher
c'est l'une des aberrations de la
politique viticole européenne que les
vignerons remettent en cause avec jean
françois robin est le problème de la
viticulture est ce que l'on sait déjà du
rapport lauga
va-t-on vers une nouvelle crise viticole
ou laisse-t-on craindre le pire pour
obtenir satisfaction
cette année tout repose sur un mot
chaptalisation pour chaque région de la
communauté européenne
il y à une réglementation particulière
pour le sucre âge du vin il est tout
simplement interdite dans le midi de la
france languedoc roussillon et corse
pour les viticulteurs de ces régions
cette situation est particulièrement
grave car la récolte est mauvaise ce
sera le cas dans beaucoup de vignobles
un exemple qui résume bien la situation
le jurançon dans le sud ouest
hélas comme tout le monde les
contournements nous avons il va courir
et les conséquences des mauvais temps de
juin et juillet et nous avons eu deux
pays les médiaux la cause des pluies du
mois d'août retire totalement attaqué la
récolte dans les vignobles de vingt
tableaux le degré faible et on veut
enrichir des spécialistes propose la
technique de l'enrichissement par des
concentrés de mou
les jus de raisin l'institut technique
du vin qui a fait des essais laisse
entendre que la qualité n'en souffre pas
bien au contraire les syndicats de
viticulteurs du midi n'en sont pas
convaincus et réclament la liberté
totale
en clair ils préfèrent employer le vrai
sucre comme tout le monde mais dans la
profession les avis divergent
louis louga dans son rapport au conseil
économique et social est à la fois
contre le coupage et la chaptalisation
si cela est nécessaire il préfère
l'enrichissement par des concentrés de
jus ou de sucre de raisin et si le vin
ne mérite même pas d'être enrichi alors
pour lui distille le problème
fondamental de la viticulture française
c'est de produire un vin de qualité
consommables en l'état pour éviter
découpage et donc des importations qui
viennent d'autres pays et qui ajoute
justement à l'excédent français faire de
la qualité tout le monde est d'accord
mais sur les moyens d'y parvenir les
divergences sont nombreuses
là où les réactions sur les plus
violentes c'est lorsque l'on parle
d'arracher de la vigne louis louga se
contente d'évoquer la rénovation et le
ré encépagement de 450 mille hectares en
année normale les excédents sont de
l'ordre de 7 millions d'hectolitres
tandis que la consommation tend à
baisser alors que
voire moins mes meilleurs tous les
consommateurs ne sont pas d'accord autre
solution exporter plus bien sûr mais
notre réputation est basée sur les
grands vins d'appellation les vins
courants ne doivent pas décevoir car il
porterait tort à tout notre viticulture
enfin ramener la production au niveau
des besoins
cela pose un grave problème l'arrachage
des plus mauvais vignoble par quoi les
remplacer
nous manquons de maïs ou le soja par
exemple mais ces cultures sont moins
rentables dans les régions concernées
il faut donc proposer des compensations
aux viticulteurs intéressés or rien n'a
encore été fait dans ce sens je suis
vous êtes nous sommes tous quelque part
dans un fichier et même dans plusieurs
fichiers le fichier de l'école celui de
l'hôpital celui de l'armée celui de la
sécurité sociale
nous sommes en fiches pour l'emploi les
assurances le crédit le logement les
contraventions les délits plus graves si
nous n'avons commis les ordinateurs nous
garde dans un coin de leur mémoire
c'est quelquefois bien pratique pour
connaître plus vite nos antécédents et
agir efficacement en conséquence mais ça
peut être ennuyeux surtout si on relit
les ordinateurs tous ensemble à ce
moment là l'ordinateur pour vous peut
vous recracher toute votre vie dans ses
moindre incident même ceux que nous
avons oublié
il ya bien des choses dans notre vie qui
ne regarde que nous et dont on pourrait
servir contre nous c'est précisément le
problème qui a été posée aujourd'hui aux
députés avec le projet de loi
informatique et libertés il comporte une
série de dispositions très compliqué de
nombreux amendements ont été déposés par
l'opposition
tout cela vise en tout cas à limiter
strictement l'utilisation du super
fichiers afin de protéger les citoyens
contre les abus de l'informatique
à cet effet le projet prévoit une
commission nationale de contrôle et la
possibilité pour le citoyen ça c'est
important
d'accéder à son dossier pour en corriger
les erreurs avec françois de closets un
regard sur l'ordinateur et sur la
question menace-t-il nos libertés une
menace pour nos libertés
l'ordinateur peut l'être assurément dans
la mémoire des ordinateurs géants toutes
les informations fiscales judiciaires
médicales professionnelles ces autres
peuvent être rassemblés
il suffit alors
unir ces machines au sein d'un réseau
pour qu'instantanément le maître de
l'ordinateur sache tout sur chaque
citoyen la disposition de cette
information total devient alors un
formidable instrument de pouvoir et
éventuellement de pression la menace est
donc réelle mais à côté de cet aspect
négatif
il ne faut pas oublier l'aspect positif
parce que dans la grande société moderne
l'individu devient anonymes les
situations particulières disparaissent
on ne considère plus que des catégories
c'est le contribuable- malades l'ayant
droit
bref c'est la foire d'empoigné dans
laquelle les vainqueurs sont les plus
forts et les plus malins alors pour
remettre un peu de justice dans le
système
ils font reprendre en compte chaque
situation particulière c'est à dire
manier des tonnes d'informations
cela seul l'ordinateur peut le faire
grâce à lui le médecin peut tout
connaître du malade qu'il soigne la
caisse de retraite liquider rapidement
une pension grâce à lui aussi le fisc
peut dépister plus facilement des
fraudeurs la sécurité routière des
chauffards seulement il suffit de peut
faire un pas de trop pour que
l'administration plus humaines
deviennent policière et c'est toute la
difficulté il faut à la fois se garder
la possibilité d'utiliser l'ordinateur
tout en contrôlant étroitement cette
utilisation
c'est le but de la loi en discussion
alors sur les objectifs tout le monde
est d'accord
seuls les moyens sont discutées
l'opposition particulier refuse que les
membres des organismes de contrôle
soient désignés par le gouvernement et
ce point fera certainement l'objet de
longues discussions
mais une chose est assurée il faut se
réjouir que ce débat ait lieu avant que
tous ces systèmes ne soient mises en
place ont certes il existe déjà des
milliers de fichiers mais pas encore le
fichier total eh bien il n'est que temps
de garantir chaque citoyen contre un tel
risque
le débat a été très franc ce matin entre
raymond barre et les chefs d'entreprise
de la région parisienne ces derniers ont
présenté un certain nombre de
revendications assez fortes auxquelles
le premier ministre a répondu en
rappelant la priorité du redressement
économique
le gouvernement fera tout ce qui est en
son pouvoir pour éviter la france une
récession at il dit et il a demandé aux
chefs d'entreprises de poursuivre leurs
efforts notamment en matière de
modération des coûts de
production et puis garder espoir leur at
il dit nous savons tous ensemble que
nous pouvons sortir et l'enjeu ce n'est
pas seulement d'éviter à la france un
système économique et social qui serait
un système de régression un système
d'isolement de notre pays un système
d'abaissement de notre niveau de vie
c'est de sortir le pays de la crise pour
qu'ils puissent continuer à être en
europe et dans le monde
un pays qui soit crédible un pays en qui
on a confiance et quand je lis les
battrons sont découragés les patrons
sont fatigués les patrons en veulent à
l'obstination du premier ministre est
bien en fin de compte je me dis que vous
n'êtes ni désespérée ni fatigué ni
découragés et je prends sur moi la
responsabilité de tout ce qui vous
ennuie
il faut bien que quelqu'un le supporte
la supportent cette responsabilité mais
tous ensemble nous pouvons nous en
sortir et montrer par notre action
économique et sociale que dans une crise
la plus dure que le monde ait connu
depuis 30 ans et à la veille d'une
situation internationale qui restera
pendant plusieurs années difficiles
tout ce que l'économie française a fait
depuis 20 ans lui donne la possibilité
de rester une économie avec un potentiel
de développement et avec l'espoir
parallèlement l'offensive pour l'emploi
lancé donc par les chambres de commerce
et d'industrie
hier les syndicats font état de
certaines situations alarmantes
andré bergeron de force ouvrière redoute
une augmentation du nombre des chômeurs
à l'automne la cfdt dénonce de la
situation intolérable des travailleurs
du textile et la cgt dénonce aussi un
plan de resteront structurellement ont
préparé par l'établissement boussac dans
les entreprises des vosges
un plan qui selon la direction ne
comporte aucun licenciement mais des
mutations et des reconversions
enfin toujours selon la cgt
situation est aussi très grave voire
dramatiques pour les travailleurs du
groupe usinor dans la région de lille et
sur un plan plus général georges séguy
que vous entendrez interviewé par
françois godin et traditions de 23
heures a déclaré cet après midi
l'aggravation des conséquences de la
politique d'austérité notamment dans le
domaine du pouvoir d'achat et de
l'emploi exige une intensification
rapide de la lutte revendicative 800
ouvriers au chômage technique à l'usiné
renault de billancourt la direction a
annoncé cette décision ce matin au
comité d'établissement explications
depuis une semaine des matines des
manutentionnaires en grève immobilise
leur chariot et rendent impossible
l'approvisionnement des machines une
grève bouchons en quelque sorte mais
d'un style un peu particulier dans ces
cas-là on observe toujours de très près
ce qui se passe à la régie christian
dadelsen mardi dernier 150
manutentionnaire d'un atelier de petites
pièces tôlerie cessent le travail car
ils ont été rattachées à une autre
direction
ils estiment leurs emplois et leurs
avantages acquis menacés dans la nuit de
jeudi à vendredi incident selon la cgt
la cfdt des contremaîtres des cadres se
re est intervenu pour enlever des
chariots qui bloque les chaînes de
montage
la cgt parle de commando armé la
direction répond c'est de la diffamation
ce matin huit cent des 1000 employés
sont donc mis en chômage technique par
ailleurs un autre atelier est en grève
depuis une semaine à la suite de deux
licenciements
ce soir la cgt et la cfdt réclame une
négociation en ce qui concerne les
conflits en cours à la régie renault
billancourt
les syndicats cfdt cgt affirme bien fort
leur volonté de vouloir négocier
rapidement avec la direction générale
en effet ça ne coûterait pas un centime
à la direction générale de négocier sur
les conflits en cours dans la mesure où
d'un côté il s'agit de réintégrer deux
travailleurs injustement licenciés et
dans un autre secteur de lusine
d'expliquer à des travailleurs concernés
pourquoi on veut réorganiser une
restructuration dans leur secteur
explications de la direction les
chariots sont immobilisés donc
impossibilité d'approvisionner les
machines et d'évacuer les pièces
fabriquées la liberté du travail n'est
pas respectée si cela continue dit-elle
d'autres secteurs seront touchés par le
chômage technique
il faut libérer le monde est vraiment de
l'arme nucléaire voilà ce qu'a dit jimmy
carter tout à l'heure la main sur le
coeur dans son discours devant
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
un discours considéré comme important et
même courageux sur certains points les
récentes prises de position du président
des états unis en faveur des
palestiniens par exemple rencontre dans
son pays une vive opposition dans
certains milieux il faut tout de même le
savoir
pour en revenir aux armes nucléaires
jimmy carter a dit encore que les états
unis auraient recours que pour se
défendre nous avons at il ajouté
l'obligation d'enrayer et de renverser
la course aux armements et leurs
commerces
les choses étant ce qu'elles sont on ne
peut qu'applaudir au moins les
intentions affichées du président des
états unis qui par ailleurs a annoncé
qu'un accord sur la limitation des
armements stratégiques avec l'urss était
en vue un accord significatif at il
précisé les etats unis étant prêts à
réduire leurs arsenaux nucléaires de 10
20 et même 50% si l'union soviétique est
prête à en faire autant
les pays socialistes ont accueilli bien
sûr favorablement ce discours cela dit
il n'est pas du tout certain que jimmy
carter et renoncer à sa campagne pour
les droits de l'homme qui a marqué le
début de son mandat à belgrade a lieu
depuis ce matin une conférence qui
comporte cet important sujet des droits
de l'homme les dissidents soviétiques
six ont même manifesté par des
communiqués mais ça se situe dans le
cadre plus général de la détente et de
la coopération en europe participent à
cette conférence les trente cinq
signataires de la charte dancing qui en
c'est une conférence-bilan comme on dit
on va regarder comment les promesses
d'helsinki ont été tenus ou quels ont
été les défaillances qu'est ce qui a
changé dans le monde depuis deux ans
depuis helsinki
gérard saint paul helsinki août 1975
c'est l'été finlandais est la conclusion
éclatante d'un travail préparatoire
beaucoup plus obscurs qui a duré plus de
deux ans les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de 33 pays est et ouest
européens et des deux superpuissances
états unis
et urss se sont retrouvés pour la
signature solennelle d'une déclaration
d'intention une déclaration qui les
engage
mais qui ne l'ait contraint pas pour les
uns cette conclusion est un grand espoir
pour les autres une immense du prix pour
la grande majorité des états présents
c'est une étape positive de l'après
guerre
à défaut de traité de paix la plupart
des observateurs présents sont d'accord
sur un point c'est un succès
diplomatique pour l'union soviétique et
léonid brejnev car les frontières de
1945 sont désormais figée et
officiellement reconnu là où ce sont en
fait arrêter les chars de l'armée rouge
mais il ya autre chose c'est la fameuse
troisième corbeil la libre circulation
des hommes et des idées en germe
c'est déjà le malentendu de cette libre
circulation les dissidents des pays
socialistes vont faire leurs drapeaux
des documents tels que celui-ci diffusé
en décembre 75 par tf1 sur un camp de
travail près de riga en urss vont sortir
en occident un mouvement de solidarité
se crée et la nouvelle administration
américaine avec l'élection de carter et
de monde elle va bousculer les principes
de la diplomatie traditionnelle pour
aider ouvertement les dissidents et les
encourager déjà moscou agite le spectre
du retour à la guerre froide
aujourd'hui belgrade c'est eysines
qu'ibis le rendez vous deux ans après la
signature de l'acte final un rendez vous
pour faire le point mais on a laissé les
armes diplomatiques aux vestiaires les
américains qui ont d'autres soucis avec
le proche orient et les soldes ne
gâcheront pas le 60e anniversaire de la
révolution d'octobre de leonid brejnev
c'est un bilan constructif que l'on fera
parce que comme l'a dit le ministre
yougoslave des affaires étrangères dans
son discours d'ouverture les droits de
l'homme cela dépend des conditions
historiques politiques culturelles qui
varient d'un pays à l'autre
belgrade ne sera pas un tribunal la
guerre idéologique de belgrade n'aura
pas lieu
avec vous jean claude narcy les autres
nouvelles de ce journal indira gandhi a
été remise en liberté sans condition
elle avait été arrêtée vous en souvenez
pour abus de pouvoir le tribunal devant
lequel l'ancien premier ministre indien
a comparu a jugé les preuves
insuffisantes
pour garder l'accusé en détention les
chefs d'accusation retenus contre elle
sont toutefois maintenus les anciens
ministres arrêtés ont été libérés eux
aussi mais sous caution le japon connaît
lui aussi des manifestations
anti-nucléaires plusieurs centaines de
manifestants ont envahi la ville de
kashiwazaki pour protester contre la
vente d'un terrain destiné à la
construction d'une centrale nucléaire
un important service d'ordre est
intervenu pour endiguer cette marée
humaine des contestataires
on a enregistré plusieurs blessés à
faire du détournement du dc 8 de la
japan airlines le gouvernement japonais
a demandé à l'algérie le rapatriement
des pirates et des six prisonniers
libérés les japonais demandent également
la restitution de la rançon de 300
millions de centimes
le ministre japonais de la justice
monsieur fut cuda a démissionné de son
poste il s'est opposé jusqu'au bout à la
libération des prisonniers de l'armée
rouge japonaise
françois mitterrand a réuni toute la
journée les dirigeants socialistes de
chaque département pour leur faire point
par point l'historique des négociations
du sommet et de la crise nous refusons
la polémique politique mais nous ne
bougerons pas d'un pouce de notre ligne
unitaire nous ne sommes pas à la merci
de tel ou tel article de l'humanité at
il déclaré seul notre fermeté peut
amener le parti communiste à réfléchir
l'action de françois mitterrand a été
approuvé à l'unanimité y compris par les
fédérations contrôlée par le crs madame
giscard d'estaing a présidé aujourd'hui
un déjeuner qui réunissait les femmes du
club présence et promotion de la femme
française autour du thème l'importance
des associations féminines et plus
spécialement la participation des femmes
à la vie politique
constatant d'abord les changements de
société qui ont amené les françaises à
entrer de plus en plus dans la vie
active
l'épousé du président de la république a
insisté sur le rôle des associations
la participation des femmes à la vie
associative
permet de franchir et d'accompagner ces
différentes étapes de la vie avec
bonheur n'est du volontariat et de
l'initiative individuelle
les associations permettent à leurs
adhérents de faire l'apprentissage de
leurs responsabilités en cela elles sont
une école de démocratie
les associations ont donc une fonction
sociale éminente à remplir les femmes
doivent avoir leur place y apporter
leurs espoirs et leur coeur raymond
barre et dia fort et alain poher ont des
jeunes aujourd'hui avec le président de
la république au palais de l'elysée les
discussions ont porté principalement sur
la session parlementaire
c'était aussi l'occasion comme la
présidente l'a précisé pardon le
président de l'assemblée nationale à sa
sortie de l'elysée d'un tour d'horizon
général jacques chaban delmas lui a été
reçu pendant une heure et demie par
valéry giscard d'estaing officiellement
pour parler des villes jumelées dont le
maire de bordeaux est le président mais
il est probable qu'on a surtout parlé
politique l'ancien premier ministre
s'est toutefois refusé à tout
commentaire après ce tête à tête le
premier depuis l'élection présidentielle
de 1974
toujours pas de trace de la petite
graziella ortiz patino enlevé hier matin
à genève la mère de l'enfant a reçu ce
matin un coup de téléphone
on vous rappellera nous détenons bien
votre fille puis plus rien à la
télévision suisse georges ekaterina
ortiz patino ont lancé un pathétique
appel aux ravisseurs de leur fille
prenez la voie que vous voulez contactez
nous je suis disposé à aller où vous
voulez a essayé de faire ce que je peux
maintenant vous qu'être une petite fille
n'a fait pas trop souffrir calmer la
venue d'auch n'ai pas trop de drogues et
détruit si vous pouvez et puisqu'elle va
voir sa mère et son père dans quelques
jours merci prendre là nous tout ce que
je vous demande
on lui fait pas de mal pas de nouvelles
non plus du petit géorgie hoggar béraud
unique petit fils de l'industriel
pianelli enlevé hier par deux
malfaiteurs
la famille là aussi a reçu un coup de
fil laconique même scénario qu'à genève
les deux incendiaires du cs edouard
pailleron seront jugés demain par le
tribunal pour enfants de paris
le sinistre avait provoqué la mort de 20
personnes dont 16 élèves le 6 février
les deux jeunes gens avaient mis le feu
à l'établissement en allumant du white
spirit
les familles des victimes n'ont pas
l'intention de se manifester beaucoup au
cours du procès elle se réserve pour le
procès des constructeurs et architectes
le 17 novembre prochain estimant que les
responsables du drame se trouve parmi
les personnes qui ont choisi le mode de
construction
enfin pour gagner le super couple est
aujourd'hui il fallait jouer le 3 le 7
et le 6 qui rapporte pour 1 franc 177
franc 90 le temps eh bien on gère
aujourd'hui les températures ont peu
varié sur le midi méditerranéen par
contre sur les autres régions il était
plutôt en hausse
demain de la bretagne et de la vendée à
la frontière belge après un passage
pluvieux des éclaircies apparaîtront
mais de nouvelles pluies accompagnées de
vents forts atteindront la bretagne et
la normandie
sur le reste du pays le temps sera très
nuageux et pluvieux les puits sont
fortes sur le sud des alpes et cévennes
et le midi méditerranéen sur les régions
s'étendant du bordelais à la lorraine
les pluies matinales seront suivies
d'une amélioration quand même les vents
se renforceront et les températures
maximales seront en baisse l'a cette
fois il ya vingt ans une petite boule de
métal de 83 kg s'est mise à tourner
autour de la terre beat by elle semblait
défier les lois de la pesanteur cette
espèce nique ou spoutnik 1 qui entrait
dans la légende
c'était comme un défi de l'homme à la
nature c'était surtout un défi des russo
américain ce 4 octobre 57 si les russes
triomphé dans l'espace les américains
étaient médusés et un peu jaloux même
s'il refusait de montrer cette petite
boule de métal allait changer le cours
de l'humanité au défilé soviétique
les américains répondirent par la course
vers la lune ce fut l' escalade du
cosmos
les deux grands s'affronter à coups de
satellites et de fusées de milliards de
roubles et de dollars en 20 ans nous
avons connu la plus formidable évolution
dans l'histoire de la technologie et
cela nous a valu en tout cas des images
inoubliables
un album que nous feuilletons en ce
moment avec michel chevalet qui la
composent et
il y en a marre des pilotes
bonne soirée à tous au nom de toute
l'équipe de tf1 actualité dernier
journal avec jean pierre pernaut vers
23h20 merci